Одна зі сфер, де квантові обчислення можуть покращити машинне навчання,
пов'язана з ядерними функціями або
ядерними матрицями — розгляньмо, що це таке.
Щоб розібратися, нагадаємо собі
три речі: чому скалярні добутки з'являються в машинному навчанні,
чому задачі машинного навчання оперують багатовимірними просторами
та що таке ядерні функції.
Нагадаємо: скалярний добуток або внутрішній добуток
двох n-вимірних векторів a
та b дорівнює добутку їхніх довжин
та косинусу кута між ними.
Це еквівалентно множенню
кожної компоненти вектора a на відповідну компоненту
вектора b та підсумовуванню. Зауваж: якщо вектори
майже ортогональні — наприклад, коли a
має нульові компоненти там, де b має великі,
скалярний добуток малий — це рівнозначно тому,
що кут наближається до π/2.
Аналогічно, якщо a має від'ємні компоненти, а b —
додатні,
тобто вектори вказують
майже в протилежні сторони
і кут близький до π,
результат скалярного добутку може бути
від'ємним. І нарешті, якщо a має великі компоненти там, де b
теж має великі компоненти одного знаку,
тобто вектори майже паралельні й кут близький до нуля,
скалярний добуток буде великим
та додатним. Отже, цілком логічно очікувати, що скалярні добутки
слугуватимуть зручною мірою схожості
між точками даних. Не всі n-вимірні дані
можна легко розділити в (n-1)-вимірному зрізі —
тобто лінією,
площиною або гіперплощиною. Якщо дані погано розділяються
в n вимірах, можна вкласти точки даних
у простір більшої розмірності — скажімо, m вимірів, де m
більше за n. Це називається відображенням ознак
і часто позначається як x → φ(x), де
φ(x) — відображення з n-вимірного простору дійсних чисел до
m-вимірного простору дійсних чисел.
Найлегше це уявити,
«вигинаючи» одновимірні дані у
двовимірний простір або вкладаючи двовимірні дані
у три виміри.
Але на практиці ми часто вкладаємо дані в простори з тисячами
чи навіть мільйонами вимірів.
Різниця між скалярним добутком тривимірних векторів і скалярним добутком
двовимірних — незначна.
Але скалярний добуток мільйоновимірних векторів
стає абсолютно непосильним завданням
для великих наборів даних.
Тому люди придумали хитрий прийом.
А що, якби використати проєкцію
у вищі виміри такого спеціального вигляду,
щоб скалярні добутки векторів у
вищому просторі були простою функцією від
векторів у нижчому просторі? Тобто знайти відображення
з наших даних x у вищовимірний φ(x)
таке, що внутрішній добуток у
просторі ознак виражається через
просту функцію від даних у нижчому вимірі.
Ця функція k називається ядерною функцією.
В ідеалі ми б хотіли, щоб ця ядерна функція
була функцією від внутрішнього добутку
у нижчому вимірі — це дало б нам
найкращий із обох варіантів: дуже високовимірний простір ознак,
але з дешевим і легко обчислюваним внутрішнім добутком.
На перший погляд може здатися,
що це взагалі неможливо. Розгляньмо
один простий приклад у дуже малих вимірах.
Розглянемо таке конкретне відображення ознак: воно перетворює
тривимірний вектор у
дев'ятивимірний простір. Виявляється,
що внутрішній добуток у дев'ятивимірному просторі ознак
просто дорівнює внутрішньому добутку в оригінальному
тривимірному просторі, піднесеному до квадрату. Отже, внутрішній добуток
у відображеному просторі через функцію φ
потребував би обчислення кожної з
дев'яти координат для
першого вектора і дев'яти для
другого, а потім самого внутрішнього добутку, що є
ще дев'ятьма множеннями та сумою —
загалом двадцять вісім операцій.
Ядерна функція потребує лише трьох множень
та двох сум — тобто всього чотири операції.
І це лише для відображення тривимірної точки даних у
дев'ятивимірний простір ознак.
Легко уявити, наскільки вигідним це може бути
для просторів дуже великої розмірності.
Ядерна функція — це, як правило, неперервна функція,
яку можна застосувати до будь-якого вектора в твоєму наборі даних.
Але ядерні функції використовують, беручи
пари точок даних із набору
як аргументи. Застосування ядерної функції до
кожної пари точок у наборі
дає симетричну матрицю — ядерну
матрицю. Тип ядерної функції залежить від
твоєї задачі. Підсумуємо:
опис схожості векторів у наборах даних
часто потребує внутрішніх добутків, а внутрішні добутки в
дуже високовимірному просторі ознак стають витратними.
Тому використовують відображення ознак, що відповідають
певним спеціальним ядерним функціям,
які роблять обчислення ефективнішими.
Але ця прив'язаність до спеціальних ядерних функцій
обмежує, які саме відображення в простір ознак можна
виконати ефективно. Це
може заважати добре розділити дані.
Якби існував інший спосіб…
Саме тут на сцену виходять квантові обчислення.
Відображення ознак у дуже висококовимірний простір, що відповідає
ядерним функціям, можна виконати
на квантовому комп'ютері. У квантовому оцінювачі ядер
ядерна матриця k обчислюється,
і після цього для розв'язання задачі можна використати класичний алгоритм машинного навчання.
Для цього одна точка даних x₁
завантажується та відображається, потім
завантажується інша — x₂,
і теж відображається. Оскільки внутрішній добуток двох квантових станів
пов'язаний з імовірністю вимірювання,
ми можемо оцінити внутрішній добуток двох відображених
точок даних, зробивши достатньо багато вимірювань
отриманого circuit. Таким чином наш circuit
може розповісти нам про внутрішній добуток
у будь-якому висококовимірному просторі, який circuit здатний змоделювати,
— без жодного класичного обчислення внутрішнього добутку або
ядерної функції. Існує багато способів
налаштування та вдосконалення цих методів,
і справді постійно пропонуються нові підходи,
які тестуються. Сподіваємося, цей
огляд допоміг окреслити
застосування квантових обчислень
до методів машинного навчання,
особливо тих, що стосуються ядерних функцій.